Now let's have a little more fun by
combining operators and assignment.
Let's create a variable called
totalPayroll and set it equal to zero.
Let's also create some other
variables to hold the salaries of
three hypothetical players
on say an athletics team.
One way we could calculate the total
payroll with salaries is to do this,
which isn't too bad.
It all fits on one line, but
in certain cases we may only want
to add one salary at a time.
And if we were to do this then
our calculations would change to
say something like this.
And in this case we add one salary
at time to the existing value of
the total payroll.
So this isn't too bad.
If we want out of one at a time, but
we can do better than this by combining
assignment and
the plus operator all at the same time.
And we can do this by using
the operator we want, in this case,
the addition operator
followed by an equal sign.
And while this may be
confusing at first,
let's look at how the operator
reads from left to right.
First we want to add to our existing
value and then we want to assign.
And we can also do this with
other operators like subtraction
multiplication division and
the modulus operator.
So I go ahead and fix this up, and
now we get the same value by combining
the addition and assignment for
this addition assignment operator.
If you want to see this with a different
operator, we can change all the signs to
subtraction signs, and
now our total payroll is -2,500,000.
And this would be more appropriate
if we wanted to show the deficit
after paying our players, as opposed to
the total payroll that we saw earlier.